et je me tourne vers vous en tant que
Mariotti bonjour
concrètement dès aujourd'hui tous les
réservistes et les militaires aguerris
pourront être appelés pour aller
combattre en Ukraine c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre nos esprits on nous parle
d'une mobilisation partielle certaine
mobilise pas tout le monde enfin
partielle c'est tout le même 300000
personnes si on en croit Vladimir
Poutine et son ministre de la Défense
Sergio qui s'est exprimé juste après
alors c'était on l'a vu une adresse à la
Nation avec un ton martial une adresse
enregistrée d'ailleurs qui devait avoir
lieu hier qui finalement pour des
raisons obscures a été repoussée à ce
matin donc 300000 personnes ça ne
concerne pas les étudiants par exemple
mais uniquement des réservistes qui ont
selon Vladimir Poutine et son ministère
de la Défense et bien qu'on déjà une
expérience du combat pour autant ils
doivent recevoir une nouvelle formation
militaire donc il va être intéressant de
voir un petit peu dans les semaines à
venir qui va être réellement concerné en
tout cas le décret était signé cette
mobilisation elle avait déjà de toute
façon en partie lieu officiellement
c'est pour remplir les objectifs fixés
depuis le début par MOS des objectifs
qui disent que disent qui selon Vladimir
Poutine pardonnez-moi n'ont absolument
pas changé depuis le début il la redit
d'ailleurs qu'il soutenait les
référendum d'annexion qui ont été
annoncés hier et qui vont commencer dans
les jours qui viennent dès après-demain
jusqu'au 27 exactement il dit d'ailleurs
que c'est son devoirs morales je cite de
protéger les habitants de ces régions
des néonazis au pouvoir à Kiev des nazis
qui sera donc soutenu par l'Occident
selon lui parce qu'il parle d'une guerre
directe avec l'Occident son ministre de
la Défense là d'ailleurs redit donc les
Occidentaux sont concrètement soit des
néonazis soit au pire leur soutien ou au
mieux c'est vrai qu'on a tous un
souvenir fabuleux des nazis
naturellement donc voilà il accuse
directement l'Occident en tout cas de
vouloir détruire la Russie les mots sont
assez forts et il dit qu'il est prêt à
utiliser ça c'est vraiment à retenir
tous les moyens sans citer le nucléaire
mais tous les observateurs russes le
site notamment des médias d'État comme
recette ou des et il dit qu'il est prêt
à utiliser tous les moyens pour protéger
protéger son peuple ce n'est pas du
bluff dit-il alors je rappelais le
contexte avancer éclaire un fulgurante
des forces ukrainiennes on attendait une
une réponse des Russes le timing n'est
pas du tout anodin non tout est fait
finalement pour convaincre son opinion
publique convaincre ses soutiens aussi
et ne pas laisser trop longtemps
finalement les médias s'attardait sur
les gains territoriaux et la
contre-offensive réussie de Kiev que
vous venez d'évoquer notamment dans la
région de harkis on assiste finalement
d'une certaine manière à une
contre-offensive russe alors militaire
pas encore elle est en préparation
puisqu'il nous l'annonce mais aussi
évidemment sur le terrain médiatique
même si à l'extérieur des frontières
russes personne n'est dupe il y a donc
cette mobilisation qui est annoncée il a
réclamé hier aux industriels de
l'armement et bien d'augmenter
rapidement d'accélérer les capacités de
production pour je cite aller au plus
vite permettre de livrer les armements
nécessaires à son armée ça veut dire
aussi qu'il en manque et puis enfin vous
l'avez dit on l'a évoqué les autorités
qui sont installées par Moscou dans ces
régions et qui demande donc des
référendum d'annexion un dernier mot
peut-être Antoine parce que c'est assez
rare pour pour être souligné Moscou à
communiquer des chiffres aujourd'hui
5937 de ses soldats sont morts depuis le
début de la guerre c'est le bilan avancé
hein c'est le bilan avancé un bilan
officiel c'est assez rare c'est un
chiffre qui est énorme même et même s'il
est très probablement sous-estimé à
titre de comparaison vous avez 5937
morts officiellement russe en huit mois
de guerre ça fera 8 mois dans trois
jours mais vous en avez eu moins de la
moitié des Américains en 20 ans en
Afghanistan donc rien que ça ce chiffre
est énorme ils sont très probablement
faux et sous-estimer la scia le
directeur où William Burns estimé fin
juillet il y a deux mois de ça que les
pertes russes étaient autour aux
alentours de 15000 donc vous voyez on
est sur des chiffres absolument
gigantesques évidemment ces paroles
contre parole on ne peut pas vérifier le
nombre précis de soldats russes merci
beaucoup Antoine en tout cas pour le
décryptage il devrait y avoir un certain
nombre de réactions évidemment à ce